shoes are completely overrated at this
point in the evening they are so
overrated they are so overrated come on
and here standing to get in here get in
here get in here get in here bring those
bring those this is for you this is our
gift for you that is your fleas big it's
for big please it's for big please your
face when you first one you're like no
was it the shock and they say no you're
a woman
no but how amazing is it to be the girl
the woman of the moment no no no cuz
Julia wasn't here and so it Brett if he
wasn't nominated so I'm just throwing
this out there I'm just throwing that
out there thank you it's an honor to ya
but also I mean she's just one of the
people that I most wanted to meet in the
world
yeah she was and I think we've all gone
a bit mad and then in the room next door
were oh yeah no it's it's it's it's
amazing and she's she's been someone
that I've just admired and watched for
years and years and years now I've met
her and it's amazing was it and did you
realize you kind of like took it in for
a second when they called your name what
goes through your brain I think just I
think we honestly what happens is the
feeling of how small we started and then
just that amazing expanding feeling of I
can't believe we got here and that our
little gang is so little but there was
such a there was just so much heart and
love in it and just just gratitude and
love and just so happy okay gang
little gang has done so much weird how
did this gang do it in how are you with
the woman that all Hollywood wants to
work with we love her yeah I feel I feel
so lucky to you know know her and that
she wrote all of us these characters and
created this world and though I'm so
lucky to have you know met these people
who I got to act with and our director
Harry Brad beer and the whole crew right
anybody else we're talking about streaks
and all that stuff but it is a
phenomenal achievement the writing yes
but I think but the incredible
performance and I'm just so pleased that
the performance is husband recognized
because that's a no mean feat to be able
to write all that and perform in the
acting and the acting alone is amazing
so we have to let you go where's the
party tonight
you tell Jeff Bezos he owes you some
money
[Music]